Hello! I am David Kaplan, and I am not an
expert, but I hope in this series to learn
as much as possible and explain it to you
the best way I can.
How did life begin? Or,at least, how did life begin on Earth?
This
is a question that many of us are curious about
and biologists are working extremely
hard to try to figure it out. One possible
way this could have happened is that there
was a single or single type of biological
molecule that eventually evolved into all
of life. Now a reason to think something like
that might have happened is that all life
we know on Earth contains the same biological
molecules — namely DNA, RNA and amino acids.
RNA is particularly interesting because not
only does it encode genetic information it
also can act as a catalyst for chemical reactions.
So one hope is that RNA formed in the early
times on the Earth before there was life and
then began to replicate itself. So, that sounds
maybe very simple but it’s extraordinarily
complicated. First, simply by the fact that
we don’t know what the early Earth looked
like. However, there has been some progress
in creating subunits of RNA in a laboratory
with very simple chemical compounds and ultraviolet
light. A subunit of RNA is a phosphate molecule,
a sugar molecule and a base. There are four
kinds of bases. We can label them with letters:
A, G, U and C. And those letters in a sense,
when you have a strand of them, tell a story.
They contain an enormous amount of information,
and there is your genetic code. So if in a lab
you can see how just from chemical processes
you can produce a subunit of RNA and then
watch RNA grow and eventually — if it’s
possible — have it replicate itself, then
you’ve at least demonstrated the possibility
of how life could have formed. Now of course
life could have started not with RNA but something
even before that, with molecules that don’t
exist now. Say like proto-RNA. Or perhaps
life actually came from another planet. It
landed here on a meteor and it began to grow
once it found the favorable conditions of
the Earth. We don’t know, but our best way
of figuring it out is going through the processes
of reproducing what may have happened at the
beginning of life.